let's talk about new love because every
night is still a date night for
newlyweds Nick Jonas and Priyanka Chopra
but here's the weird thing
not everyone is feeling the love Kelty
Knight joins us from New York with more
what's going on why isn't everybody on
this Love Train listen in the words of
Nick Jonas himself sometimes people get
a little jealous and the specific target
Priyanka herself and her new family is
not having it this as her and Nick's
honeymoon tour rolls on a new video of
the newlyweds arriving in Mumbai as
Priyanka makes an Instagram official her
married name Priyanka Chopra Jonas BOE
composted this romantic video of Nick
playing guitars Priyanka glides around a
dance floor but Hollywood's hottest
couple got a blast of icy water after an
article from the cut alleged Priyanka's
love for Nick isn't real labeling the
Bollywood star a global scam artist
writer Mariah Smith claims Nick was only
looking for a fling and that Priyanka
set her sights on marrying an American
star the response was immediate and
forceful Nick's big brother Joe defended
the couple tweeting what neck and pre
have his beautiful love Thank You next
his fiancee sophie turner who was also
promised bridesmaid tweeted this is
wildly inappropriate and totally
disgusting the cut has pulled the
article stating we found this story did
not meet our standards we've removed it
and apologized
you